Let's see how a simple hierarchy works in practice. I'll make a robot with two
parts to its arm, a forearm and an upper arm. This is kind of a classic computer
graphics example, except that my robot is going to be a T850. The forearm is
this piece made of six objects. I run some tests on it and it looks good. I've
made it so that the point where I'll attach it to the upper arm is at the
origin. I do this because I know that when a rotation is applied, the rotation
happens with respect to the point at the origin. Here's the code to create my
forearm, there's not a lot to it. I create an Object3D, i call,
createRobotExtender, and then I add the forearm to the scene, so I can see it.
My createRobotExtender function adds a bunch of geometric objects to the forearm
object. A faLength is passed in to let this function know how tall to make the
extender. It doesn't really matter what I add to the forearm object. The only
rule is that whatever I put into this object, I need to remember that this
object will itself rotate around the origin. I designed my upper arm in the same
way and coded up about the same. Again, it rotates around the origin. The bit
we're interested in is how these two objects get hooked together so that the
forearm is the child of the upper arm. Here's the code that attaches the two
objects together. We make the two arm pieces the same as before. The key
difference is that instead of adding the forearm to the scene itself, we add the
forearm to the upper arm. We also move the forearm to be at the top of the upper
arm. At this point the upper arm can be moved around, rotated, scaled and all of
its parts will be transformed in the same way. This is why we name this object
to be the arm instead of the upper arm, since in fact it holds both the upper
arm and the forearm. For example, if we set a rotation on the arm, the whole
object will rotate. What's important to realize here is that the arm doesn't
particularly know or care what's inside any of its children. When I add the
forearm to the arm, the forearm becomes just another part of the arm, no
different than adding a simple sphere or block. However, since we can manipulate
any object by changing its transforms, we can also change the position of the
forearm itself. So changing the angle with this line of code, will change the
angle of the forearm without affecting anything else. The transform order is the
forearms rotation and translation, followed by the arms rotation and
translation. This means the forearm can be transformed however you wish, without
knowing about the arm as a whole. The arms transforms are applied later. Give
the demo a try to see how the two parts interact with their separate controls.